[Music]
there was a guy I was living above a
grocery store in Washington and they
can't [ __ ] find him till this day
what or like in the rapture to be or
thought she what
yes so this happened in Washington this
dirty supermarket yeah that's great
cause we're all like a [ __ ] right
yeah because you can't crawl on up here
you'll just fall right through oh that's
genius you have all the supplies you
need downstairs yeah Phil they this
grocery store it they have been there
have been several reports of possible
break-ins and employees claiming that
they hear footsteps coming from the
ceiling and also there was this employee
this one time saw like feet dangling
from the ceiling and then they
disappeared so they've been calling the
cops at one point the cops spent like
four hours combing everything they
couldn't find was doing good no he's
like poaching the cops he just [ __ ]
junkies ones at the front door probably
right he comes out and he starts
shopping he's smart here's some
surveillance footage of this dude also
he's he's in there yes wait where's this
at Washington in a grocery store is this
after-hours I'm not sure that was
dressed like a ninja it looks like it
cuz it looks super dead so what does he
do like have a dinner there and then go
back in his in the top yeah he just
crawled out really quick yeah yeah he
just crawled out of the cash register so
he's not stealing like money he is the
first time oh um not money but they're
saying that he has stolen thousands of
dollars of worth of cigarettes and
liquors we just sitting there smoking
and drinking and so they're saying that
there have been five occasion losses
since Christmas day that he has been
breaking in and [ __ ] and they're just
saying like we can't [ __ ] find this
guy like what the hell could wait this
crisp
like yeah like less than a month ago hmm
but now he disappeared he doesn't show
up anymore it's not in surveillance
footage or anything no it is like
occasionally it'll happen again it keeps
popping out Charlie nothing they can't
find out Wow so I'm thinking but he
probably like found this really tiny
like little opening yeah like something
no I think he's he might be in there
living in it because they're saying they
could hear those footsteps I don't know
but I think he found it somewhere where
he can like burrow into the building
somehow and hide when they're searching
and then he's come out that kind of
reminds me when I was a kid I used to
like to hide in places to freaked my mom
out me too so one of my favorite things
to do that she could never find me is my
mom would have all her suitcases in the
luggage and in her closet and I would
open a suitcase and I'd climb in the
suitcase I closed the zippers so I could
see her and she's like looking
everywhere she's even looking in the
closet I can hear like the UH
oh gosh but I I'm just like in the life
you know what do I need 200 I love that
you think that she couldn't find you but
as a kid I'm pretty sure she saw you
she's like [ __ ] yeah some peace and
quiet finally doing her nails my thing I
fell asleep hiding in between blankets
in the closet and the cops came and
found me because my mom was freaking the
[ __ ] out she couldn't find me anywhere
and I woke up cuz cops were like what
the flashlights like they were digging
everywhere I told my mom I was running
away from home and she called that one
one for me and I was like it was the
first time I got woken up by cops the
second time was cuz I didn't go to
school and my mom got mad at me she
called the cops what uh oh he was he did
this so um I usually would get a so this
is in high school I would get a ride
with the neighbor but then that neighbor
didn't go to school that day she was
sick or something
so I asked my mom to give me a ride to
school and she said no take the bus it
sound like well imma [ __ ] [ __ ] brat
you know like I think I was
team yeah like about 15 years old so I'm
like well fine you're not gonna take me
then I'm not gonna go so I took a nap
and then I wake up two three cop cars
outside my house and like these
policemen they're flashing it go get
your backpack we're taking you you know
what they said they're like get the [ __ ]
up you [ __ ] loser go to [ __ ]
school I think big cuts at me and I was
just like what the [ __ ]
like it was crazy and I'm like this is
exaggerating just cuz I didn't go to
school you're gonna have all these
cotton like this is a waste of taxpayers
money
oh my god Dora the Explorer backpack
instant bad guy the fogger bob was
tripping out so pissed I'm like this is
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] she had to call the
cops she could have just dragged me her
cell I don't know if I called the cops a
lot Ron it seems like I know my god is
not eating her [ __ ] top Robin don't
worry we're on it listen you hungry
[ __ ] I love here in this it's like once
a month I hear a story read site it's a
McDonald Rihanna chicken nuggets so
people called the cops I just scrolled
past an article I said this kid called
the cops because his fake ID didn't come
in the mail like someone stole is this
man happening he's like where's my fake
ID I need the police yeah I ordered this
brick of cocaine and it's gone dude
there is mail theft and that's worth
like 10 G's yeah as long as well where
this guy called the cops because a
hookers stole money from him oh yeah I
love the ones worth they bust some guy
and he's like some pastor or some [ __ ]
or some millionaire great dad who's like
picking up hookers and like like like a
suburban like weird area and they always
the guys always like oh [ __ ] please
don't tell anybody
the always is like uptight Church never
do they're immediately swearing and like
being like oh god please don't tell my
wife
yeah like a Georgia politician or
something that was like super into like
anti-gay stuff and he in and he got
caught in an airport bathroom sucking
yeah
the guy who kicked the guys leg
underneath the stall right and then yeah
you got it I don't know you tried do you
have the guy climb over and suck a dick
how do you even initiate that like
really you'd like this right and then
you kick you kick their leg under the
what would you react if that happen
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing did
that to me I would have grabbed the
toilet paper and threw it under for them
I bet you'd like to say it good I suck
your dick
cut straight to the point right there
you're right first of all my name is
James how are you who are you haven't
seen my dick yeah Wow
I feel like you'd be down for what I
don't know to get bathroom head maybe
from I do know it's my thing
I thought you'd be down to have a dude
suck your dick yeah would you rather get
your dick yes maybe I've been waiting
for you go I mean I'd rather be get your
dick sucked by a chick who sucks at it
or a dude who's [ __ ] good at it I
just would rather the hair oh yeah you
got a guy yeah but this guy is really
good I'll make you comment like this guy
could suck dick for an hour and a half
that's not a president of me this one is
me head is an appetizer right you go to
you yeah yeah it's like the soup or
something right you don't go to lb the
Chili's or Friday's anything for that
it's just like oh wow hole feels better
than a vagina that's not possible
cuz butt holes won't live okay I hear
you I'm hearing you but what if
sometimes you get the app you go to your
go to Outback Steakhouse you get the
bloomin onion like I don't think I can
eat anything else yeah maybe this is
like that cuz it's so good it's just so
[ __ ] oh there for the entrees I'm
never going to risk my strictly for the
apps you've never been a soup plantation
the whole thing is just appetizer it
really is you got soup you got chili and
you got like
you convinced yourself while you do eat
out of the app though they don't have
entrees you can slum it and go to soup
plantation but you can't have some guys
suck your dick give me a [ __ ] break
here nothing's on me you never been to
Olive Garden and just got the soup and
salad I've never been Olive Garden oh
well you try to go a lot of carbs do not
love me I already got my mom's hips I
can't add anything to this luck you know
not cuz my milkshake brings all the boys
to the yard and now I'm running and I
can't go back home oh wait leg back no I
wouldn't get that I wouldn't I wouldn't
have the guy suck my dick unless it's a
peep it's a dick hole thing why stick my
dick inside the hole just don't want to
face mad face cannot get me hard
well what if you do that and you feel
some facial hair like some stubble you'd
ever go for this I'll be like damn this
girl got stubble no because I'm not
gonna let myself go oh man
yeah I'm gonna be like oh it's a bearded
lady he's more committed that's smart
you think she quit the carnival just a
sudden glory all different different job
you know no she got laid off from the
fun
you called that a different you call
that a change of environment she's
staring at the [ __ ] wall waiting for
dick to come through well she doesn't
have haters is that a turn-on at all for
anyone in real life what a glory hole is
glory holes
never seen it on anything other than a
point like I've never [ __ ] like
something back some back backdoor
[ __ ] diners and I've never seen glory
holes they have one in the movie don't
you know so you know it's real yeah
exactly movies but I've never seen a
real one me too I noticed in a real I
have maybe you're not looking even
though but not us stop bathrooms but
like you know how you can see you can
only see this [ __ ] that you're like
focusing are you looking yeah just a
minute
do not call the numbers they were like
for a good time I should never have us
never
glory holes in Japan do they really
sometimes the members disconnected yeah
I feel like now with technology they
don't need glory holes anymore
we have like tinder or Grindr or
whatever have you ever at home the
college below huh there's this one kind
of porn that I really really like it's
like a they have this massage table in a
hole where you your dick goes through it
and then there's like a hot girl that
goes under and then she think that I
would my I think my head would explode
if I was getting like a massage and head
at the same time I feel like that would
be so like so much pleasure my body
would know how to handle you by farting
class yeah I wouldn't mind now I
wouldn't mind that but I would like I
would my father I would like to try that
so I don't understand how it happens so
how is your body being massage while
you're getting head to people what if it
was three it's somebody's besides like
the lower back check his sucking your
dick and the dude is massaging your back
is that okay that's perfect yeah I got a
massage only had two besides what I got
once right yeah he didn't like it I like
it more I didn't like it let me tell you
why let me tell you why
so I went to I call Massage Envy and I
said my palmer there was like gonna set
you up with Jenny so I'm like cool Jimmy
sounds fine right
get there Jimmy is a 6-4 280 pound
Armenian guy write anything about a
million guys Harry is [ __ ] right so he's
putting the oil on my back and he's
doing like the back set saying I feel
every [ __ ] follicle possible he's like
is this pressure okay I think the
pressure is fine just [ __ ] on that I
don't prefer right then when he came to
the front he's like doing this point
right here he had just ain't like he had
to just be like a Reese's Peanut Butter
Cup or something like that cuz it's just
that's it peanut butter and chocolate
just omitting like it wasn't like peanut
butter candy it had to be a Reese's Cup
doesn't have that they're nuts same
amount of peanut butter chocolate but
still it's just like oh I didn't I
didn't sign and I'm completely like
comfortable of my masculinity like and I
don't care if it's a guy but it's just
the hair yeah
I recommend it again because I think
this the the man's hands is blunt and
it's and it's strong so you could get
some [ __ ] good ass massage work done
but a ladies maybe Asian man cuz you
guys barely have any hair yeah oh
they're going Thomas eyes this year so a
chick sucking dick while Asian man
working on your back completely fine
yeah yeah
[Music]